بالطبع السوداني يواجه اخطار لها علاقه
بالانفلات الامني واختار لها علاقه
بالتقسيم وان كانت الاخطار اليها علاقه
بالتقسيم هي اقل
احتماليه في الحدوث ولكن هي موجوده لو
استمرت للحرب دي لفترات طويله ممكن يبقى
بعد كده تتحول كل سيناريوهات لسيناريوهات
لها علاقه بالتقسيم ولكن سيناريوهات
الانفلات الامني هي سيناريوهات وارده
وحقيقه هي حصلت فعلا الحاجه اللي حصلت في
مدينه جنينه هي نوع من الانفلات الامني
بسبب
وجود هشاشه في تلك المناطق وجود صراعات
قبليه في سيناريو مهم وهي اصوات بدات تظهر
عن تسليح المواطنين
للمشاركه في دعم
القوات المسلحه ولكن ده حيواجه بين ناحيه
اخرى برضو دعوات لتسليح مجموعات تانيه
خصوصا انه الصراع الدائره فيه الى حد ما
نواحي قبليه لانه تدعم الطرف الثاني واللي
هو الدعم السريع كل الموضوع ده هيؤدي في
الاخر لانه ممكن يدخلوا مجموعات مسلحه غير
منتظمه في انها تعجيج الصراع في مناطق
مختلفه من السودان
مسارات الحلول في السودان يجب ان تبتدئ
اولا بمسار عاجل ومهن وهو قيام هدنه
متماسكه يستطيع من خلال المدنيين الحصول
على مسارات امنه للخروج من مناطق القتال
مسارات لتوفير الخدمات الطبيه وعوده
الخدمات الاساسيه من كهرباء ومياه وتوفير
المعونات الانسانيه للمدنيين داخل مناطق
النزاع الحرب في اساسها هي حرب سياسيه
الحل الشامل يجب ان يكون حل سياسي مبني
على قيام دوله يسود فيها القانون تفصل
فيها السلطات ويكون فيها جيش سوداني قومي
موحد تدمج فيه كل الحركات المسلحه الحاليه
للموقعه الاتفاقيات السلام ثم بناء نظام
قانوني وقطائي متماسك بنفس المستوى حتى
يستطيع ان يحاسب كل من ساهم في جرائم ترقه
الى جرائم ضد الانسانيه خلال هذه الحرب او
ما سبقه محاسبه كل المطورطين فيها
وتقديمهم للقانون وفقا للقوانين التي تسود
في السودان ثم بناء نظام سياسي يسمح
للتداول السلطه بدمقراطيه بين الاطراف
المختلفه لحكم السودان
في غالبيته هي تاثيرات ايجابيه
بدات من اول بدايه القتال بمبادلات من
الاتحاد الافريقي من دول الايجارات من دول
مجاوره زي اثيوبيا جيبوتي
جنوب السودان وحتى تدخلات دوليه من دول زي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي مواصله
لجهود كانت موجوده اصلا قبل بدايه القتال
وحاليا الامين العام للامم المتحده موجود
في افريقيا لمناقشه الوضع في السودان
ومحاوله ايجاد حلول
بواحده من اكثر الحالات ايجابيه هو حتى
موافقه الطرفين على مبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه للجلوس والتفاوض ووجود ممثلين
اليهم في مدينه جده للتفاوض على الاقل
لاول خطوات الحل وجود تدخلات ايجابيه لا
يعني بيحل من الاحوال من تجاهل بعض
التدخلات التي تؤثر سلبا على الصراع
الدائره في السودان بدعم بعض دول الجوار
لاحدى الاطراف ضد الطرف الاخر او بعض
الدول في الاقليم التي تحاول ان تخلق
تحالفات مع بعض الاطراف لدعمها وينها
الصراحه اسرع لصالحها